[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abidjan ville durable ça vous évoque
quoi je vous pose cette question parce
que quand on vit à abidjan quand on
arrive à abidjan
c'est vrai que le développement durable
c'est parce qu'ils nous saute aux yeux
tout de suite si cette réunion s'était
passé un soir de semaine à l'heure de
pointe
beaucoup d'entre vous se serait posé la
question de vous rendre ici les
embouteillages le stationnement
finalement le stress aurait pris le
dessus sur l' envie d'assister à ces
présentations bon est-ce qu'on reparle
de la lagune de la couleur la lagune qui
se baserait dans la lagune aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les déchets sur la plage
bon en réalité nous connaissons tous la
situation et le désastre écologique que
nous constatons aujourd'hui sur
l'environnement donc en réalité ce soir
nous sommes là pour réfléchir ensemble à
des solutions et surtout agir
d'ailleurs je vous propose un tour
d'horizon de ce qui fonctionne bien déjà
abidjan et des initiatives qui sont déjà
en place
mille bennes supplémentaires et beaucoup
de poubelles ont été rajoutés pour
justement améliorer la collecte des
déchets et on a réussi avec sa a
augmenté de 20% justement le taux de
collecte dans les quartiers dans les
communes d'abidjan
savez vous qu'il ya des bus électriques
qui fonctionnent à l'université au feu
de bois neave qui dessert l'université
la journée et se recharge la nuit grâce
à l'énergie solaire qui est stockée dans
des batteries
les compteurs intelligents proposé par
ses yeux la sodeci qui permettent une
meilleure gestion de la distribution et
de la consommation de l'éclairage public
basse consommation à base de panneaux
solaires à grand bassam les transport
lagunaire qui d'une certaine manière
desservent les quartiers les communes
d'abidjan en désengorgeant les axes
principaux le projet de métro qui va
aussi permettre de fluidifier
et l' axe nord sud d'abidjan
vous devrez aussi signalé les belles
initiatives de la côte d'ivoire
notamment un décret qui dans quelques
mois va permettre à chacun d'entre nous
de devenir producteur d'énergie
d'origine renouvelable grâce au décret
d'autoproduction porté par le ministère
de l'énergie
enfin je dois signaler que depuis juin
2019 le code de la construction et de
l'habitat intègre des contraintes
environnementales et les notions de
performance énergétique pour les
nouvelles constructions
alors toutes ses actions elles sont
évidemment très positive il faut
maintenant les intégrer dans un plan
cohérent et global pour inventer la
ville de demain
en prenant un peu de recul et regardons
ce qui se passe à l'échelle de la
planète depuis 2010 est plus de la
moitié de la population vit en ville et
deux cent mille personnes qui déménagent
chaque jour en 2050
ce sera 70 % de la population mondiale
qui vivra dans les villes ce qui
représente environ 3 milliards de
personnes à loger en plus dans les
villes
donc 3 milliards c'est deux fois et demi
2 2 fois pardon la population de la
chine actuelle
si on rajoute à ça le fait que les
villes sont très inefficace aujourd'hui
elle contribue a pu la moitié des
émissions de co2 à l'échelle de la
planète les pertes liées à l'énergie
représente 270 milliards d'euros par an
la nourriture c'est 170 milliards
d'euros par an la pollution de l'air 100
milliards les embouteillages 100
milliards si le statu quo est maintenu
si rien ne change si nous ne faisons
rien en 2050 il faudra l'équivalent de
trois planètes terre pour alimenter les
villes
renault en afrique sur le phénomène
démographique l'afrique est la force
motrice de ce mouvement
en 2050 la population du continent aura
été multipliée par deux et à la même
période l'essentiel du continent vivra
en ville donc en côte d'ivoire à abidjan
ce que nous constatons aujourd'hui déjà
cette pression démographique et tous les
chalets dire les dégâts et écologique
que nous constatons vont s'accélérer en
a été tout s'accélère et on ne pourra
plus faire face comme on le fait
aujourd'hui face à cette croissance
organique
par exemple si on parle de logement on
va dire on va être temps de la ville
donc on va construire des logements donc
qui dit des logements il va falloir
optimiser les transports donc on va
construire des réseaux de
l'assainissement des réseaux électriques
souvent il arrive pas en même temps
d'ailleurs et finalement deux ans après
la route elle est trop petite elle est
saturée et là vous aurez complètement
abandonné l'idée de venir à neuf
conférences au plateau à l'heure de
pointe
donc comment fait-on pour gérer cette
transition vers les villes nouvelles et
la nouvelle urbanisation regardons là
aussi ce qui se passe à l'échelle de la
planète
aujourd'hui il ya trois grandes
catégories d' approche il ya ce qu'on
appelle le phénomène global de
transition qui a été initiée par rob
hopkins en 2006 et auquel adhèrent 1000
villes dans le monde
ça consiste en quoi ça consiste à se
réapproprier son économie ses ressources
ses valeurs y compris ses valeurs
culturelles ses spécificités
pour mieux appréhender le développement
et mieux faire face aux enjeux
logistique à venir il ya aussi
l'éclosion de villenouvelle comme au
sénégal à singapour en suède
alors là j'allais dire c'est un peu plus
simple parce que elle intègre dès leur
conception les fondamentaux d'une
meilleure qualité de vie du respect de
l'environnement et les nouvelles
technologies
excusez-moi dernière approche elle est
plus local c'est ce qu'on appelle les
écoquartiers les écoquartiers c'est un
véritable incubateur de bonnes pratiques
où naissent des lotos production de
biens de services et tout ça sous l'oeil
bienveillant des autorités qui ont
compris que c'est sur ces initiatives
locales que vont peut-être née naître
les idées qui vont devenir universel
pour demain mais finalement ces trois
approches elles se rejoignent sur une
même ambition
j'allais dire une même vision la vision
d'une ville durable
une nouvelle urbanisation
éco-responsable et soutenable comme
disent les anglais ce qui m'amène à vous
parler de la smart city la ville
intelligente vous entendez ce terme
depuis une quinzaine d'années maintenant
alors on n'y a mis un peu tout et
n'importe quoi
de derrière ce terme en réalité
moi je leur formule en disant ça
consiste à mettre de l'intelligence au
service de la ville et de ses citoyens
si on revient à abidjan nous qui sommes
à 8 ans d'abidjan qu'est-ce qu'on attend
en termes de mobilité donc se déplacer
plus facilement avoir des transports
publics qui fonctionnent non polluant
c'est possible
plus fréquents qu'est ce qu'on cherche à
être dans dans des trajets qui ne
dépasse pas 20 minutes entre son lieu de
travail l'école le loisir en termes de
logement on peut habiter dans des
bâtiments bioclimatiques
écologique autonome qui respecte les
impacts environnementaux sur lequel la
performance énergétique est contrôlée
grâce aux compteurs intelligents on veut
que ce soit une ville sûre partout pour
tous on veut qu'ils aient une gestion
des déchets optimisé sachez que par
exemple à barcelone vous avez des bacs
de collecte en surface qui permet de
faire le tri qui sont interconnectés
sous terre et qui amène directement les
déchets dans les stations de traitement
donc ça c'est formidable et ça existe
en terme de stationnement par exemple à
dubaï vous avez des bornes
interconnectés qui vous indique où sont
les places libres qu'on vous approchez
d'une zone de stationnement
bref la technologie aujourd'hui permet
de construire des villes intelligentes
alors pourquoi aujourd'hui nous n'y
arrivons pas parce que en réalité ces
fondamentaux que je viens de citer le
logement la mobilité la santé la gestion
des déchets doit être couplée à une
vision politique et c'est en couplant
cette vision politique avec ses
fondamentaux le tout supporté par des
nouvelles technologies que nous verrons
l'avènement des smart cities des villes
intelligentes
alors comment y arriver
comme on dit tous les chemins mènent à
rome mais je vais essayer de vous donner
le chemin le plus court en réalité pour
construire une ville intelligente
ça commence par le déploiement d'un
système imaginé que sur notre corps
il est tout un tas de capteurs qui en
permanence nous indique les constantes
vitales de notre corps l'état de nos
articulations de notre sens et c'est
donc et kiara mensah aux médecins qui
sait en permanence qui se passe sur
notre corps reconnaissez que ça
permettrait de prévenir les maladies des
accidents et c'est donc d'une certaine
manière d'être un peu plus durable or
finalement une ville c'est aussi un
corps vivant et donc si on veut savoir
ce qui s'y passe il faut pouvoir le
mesurer et donc il faut déployer un
système parce qu'en fait on ne contrôle
bien que ce qu'on mesure
alors quand je dis ça évidemment une
ville intelligente ne se limite pas à
une série de capteurs qui remonte des
informations vers une intelligence
artificielle
il faut que ces données qui remontent ou
qu'elles soient techniques qu'elle soit
privée individuelle soit analysé traité
transforme et pourquoi parce que il faut
qu'elles servent aux pouvoirs publics
pour alimenter une vision vérifier que
ce qui se passe sur le terrain est
conforme avec ce qui a été planifiée et
pouvoir également déclencher des actions
au profit des citoyens
il faut également que ces informations
soient transformés pour qu' on puisse
créer des applications utiles pour les
citoyens donc par exemple je je je me
promène dans la rue je vois un tas
d'ordures je peux le prendre en photo
le géolocaliser et j'en vois ça
directement aux services concernés qui
va falloir planifié l'enlèvement des
ordures en question donc c'est des
applications tout simple aujourd'hui qui
peuvent exister et qu'il faut créer si
on prend la mobilité par exemple si ça
n'arrive jamais à abidjan il ya un
convoi exceptionnel et les voies sont
bloquées
bon on reste quelques heures dans la
voiture mais ça n'arrive jamais abidjan
si on recevait un message qui nous
indiquait que les taxes allaient être
coupées à telle heure on pourrait
réorganiser notre parcours choisir un
autre itinéraire ou décaler notre heure
de départ
bref vous voyez que il y a beaucoup
d'applications possibles en terme de
deux nouvelles cependant de nouveaux
usages numériques à destination des
usagers
[Musique]
alors pour conclure je voudrais reparler
de la vision politique parce qu'en
réalité tout part de là il faut qu'il y
ait une vision il faut qu'ils aient des
gens qui soient informés des nouvelles
technologies des nouvelles pratiques et
de ce point de vue là je voudrais dire
deux mots sur le rôle du club abidjan
mais durable puisque quelque part nous
sommes aux côtés des pouvoirs publics
aux côtés des universités aux côtés des
écoles aux côtés des prescripteurs pour
élaborer avec eux une vision qu'ont
construite de la ville de demain et
notre souhait que c'est que ça se fasse
le plus rapidement possible plus nous
serons nombreux à le vouloir
plus ça se produira
enfin je voudrais dire deux mots sur la
formation la formation sur deux points
vous avez vu que ces villes durables
vont permettre donc d'élaborer des
visions et d'élaborer de nouveaux usages
numériques pour les citoyens les
citoyens vont donc devenir des acteurs
encore plus des acteurs de leur ville ça
veut dire que le devoir civique qui est
le nôtre mais qui ose celui aussi des
nouvelles générations doit redevenir une
valeur centrale de la formation dès le
plus jeune âge le deuxième volet que je
voudrais évoquer sur la formation
c'est les métiers techniques
j'ai parlé de réseaux intelligents j'ai
parlé d' usages numériques
j'ai parlé d'application j'ai parlé de
déploiement de réseaux télécoms etc
eh bien tous ces métiers là ils existent
mais il va fort ancré et de ce point de
vue là je crois que la côte d'ivoire
vous présente tous les atouts pour être
vraiment le terreau favorable au
développement de ces nouveaux métiers et
le développement de nouvelles
applications pour ces nouveaux usages
numériques
donc pour finir je voudrais conclure sur
cette phrase que certains d'entre vous
connaissent sûrement c'est soyons le
changement que nous voulons pour le
monde ses gants dit qu'il a dit merci de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]